[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the great mark jackson joins us on the
program good morning mark thanks for
joining us how are you
i'm doing well thanks for having me it's
been a long time um
how would you sum up the bucks nets
yesterday game four
i think the bucks ultimately you know uh
was committed to being a lot more
physical
getting into the bodies of not just
kevin durant but the nets in general
they had tremendous success doing it
took them out of rhythm
and they were in attack mode um
offensively giannis wasn't messing
around
and he was more of a playmaker
mixing it up getting guys involved and
attacking the remnant
it allowed other guys to get going and
it allowed him to get going so it was
a perfect day for for the uh milwaukee
bucks yesterday what should the game
plan be
for giannis and his approached uh
and certainly he's a different player it
feels like in in uh
in the playoffs than he is the regular
season but
how would you have him attack the nets
well jeff and i jeff van gundy and i
agree but we disagree he thinks he
should shoot
zero three pointers or he should shoot a
hundred
it should be because he can get that
shot any time and i understand that
mentality
but my feeling is i don't have a problem
with him shooting
you know two or three three-pointers in
the rhythm of the game
so he's attacking the rim he gets a dunk
he gets a layup he gets and one
and all of a sudden the next time down
the floor he thinks he's got it going he
feels comfortable and confident
and he steps into a rhythm three i'm
fine with that
i think he's got to ultimately not take
a bunch of them
unless he's knocking him down because
you're doing the nets a favor
you're playing into their hand so he's
got to be in attack mode
with the mentality of not settling on
the offensive end
especially early setting the tone and
then he's got to be
a willing pass to take the double team
and and hit guys in rhythm on point
where those guys got to be confident and
and knock down shots also so it's got to
be a mixture of both
in my mind what is it with uh some of
these players at the free throw line
and giannis is there and it's he's like
analysis you know paralysis by analysis
and then
you've got ben simmons as well are these
all
fixable coachable things to me they are
um and it's it's it's um minimizing the
the movement it's minimizing the amount
of time i mean you stand you stand at
the free throw line you know
over 10 seconds and you're sitting there
for what you know i had a routine but
uh i didn't do a routine when i
practiced and i just didn't be quite
honest i just did it just so i could be
remembered one day by the guy that
held his hand up at the free throw line
i don't think it's a uh it would be
harming him well i know it wouldn't be
harming him if he cut
the routine short and stepped up to the
free-throw line and maybe five seconds
took a shot
he couldn't be any worse so i think he's
it is paralysis by analysis they're
overthinking it
and they can be much better free throw
shooters if they obviously they put the
time in but you get a shooting coach
with them
and you develop routines and habits and
they will become better i don't know
there
would be 90 or 95 but they certainly
would be better
but it's hard to be the guy at the end
of a game
if i can't have you hang handle the ball
because
i i don't want to put you on the free
throw line or i i can't have you go to
the free throw line
and you know with ben simmons and and
you know with the greek freak
these are more key players i i
understand what you're saying but i
disagree
um because i played with a guy like it
like let's say dale davis a
tremendous power forward that i played
with that was a historically bad free
throw shooter
but as a team we didn't care whether he
got fouled down the stretch because one
thing we knew
he wasn't afraid to shoot the free throw
he was going to step up and it won't if
he
made him miss it it wasn't going to be
because he was afraid yeah so you don't
want guys that's going to be afraid of
the moment
yeah like ben simmons i don't see i
don't see men or ariana's
afraid to shoot the free throws so you
develop the right habits
and then uh you make sure as a coach i
put them in position that where
okay we're in the bonus i'm not putting
the ball in ben simmons hands
understanding you know that they're
going to foul them and send them to the
free-throw line unless he's got a rhythm
and we got a comparable lead then okay
you want to play that game we can play
it
but i'll develop some things to keep my
best players on the floor
if you're steve nash and i said you
could have your choice you could either
have harden back with durant or kyrie
back
who would you take i want to both no
you can't have both well well the game's
tomorrow i want change on because i
don't think that kyrie irving
uh physically would be able to play
tomorrow but
uh i i i think at least just
let's say they're both healthy oh here
you go you know when i when i said i was
going to do that
i said this guy's going to ask me a
question it forced me to answer
something i don't know what it is but
i'm like i'm like scottie pippen
guarding you
okay no you're worse
wow scott do you still see scottie
pippen in your nightmares
i see him all day long what are you
talking about when i'm awake i see him
i look back sometimes and just swat his
hands off me
was he the best defender
um he was an incredible defender uh
i think when you look at a guy like gary
payton when you look at michael jordan
when you look at when you look at hakeem
elijah i mean
those guys were elite all-time great
defenders alvin robinson was a
great defender would you rather have
jordan guard you or pippin
uh i would rather have jordan guard me
if you told me if you said he had to
guard me the whole game
and it's not a knock on his defensive
you know mentality and how great he is
defensively
chatty pitman could you know dog me to
pull him out to the court and dog me for
whatever amount of time i was on the
court because he didn't have any
any pressure on him to carry the load
offensively if you ask michael to do it
just like
phil asked kobe to do it in in the
finals in 2000
kobe was great at it but he wasn't
scottie pippen because he was trying to
you know
get 40 on the other end so it was is a
different mentality
and is a different commitment when you
know this is what i have to do to win
this game
he's mark jackson uh espn nbc
or nba analyst on abc are you
third in all-time assist right now i'm
fought
uh steve nash is one ahead of me but
when i and you say oh i say oh wow
you know i when you look at the list of
guys that surround me
uh i pinch myself that's when i get you
know like it's really is unbelievable
i've got no business on that list do you
think that nash wanted to get one more
than you and then retire
no i don't think it i don't think at all
okay i know it
[Laughter]
i got chris paul at 50 assists behind
you
i think he's going to catch up oh way to
go out on a limb
lebron is 300 behind you i think he's
going to catch you
wow you are you are really feeling
yourself today with the predictions you
like charles barkley with the guarantees
paulie is there anybody else who can
catch mark jackson here before he gets
kicked out of the top ten
i didn't want to pile on but russell
westbrook is about a year away
year and a half oh man i mean but think
think about the name everybody that's
surrounds me their hall of fame is the
first
hall of fame are they already in so it's
absolutely
remarkable like i said i'm honored to be
in that position
and to be discussed with those guys are
you a hall of famer
i i'm not in the hall of fame
but do you think you should be in the
hall of fame
uh that's not up for me no no it's you
do you think like if you ask me
do you think you're better than bob
costas it wouldn't i can't go well
that's up for others you just asked me
what's your answer you out you answer
mine then i'll answer
well i finished my career second all the
time in assists i humbly submit
okay and and and and to think about all
the great players that have played in
the history of this game
to be second all-time in in a main
category
says uh says a lot and it's an
incredible
feat for me and i'm fine with where i am
in in history
and i'm i'm at peace with it
all right did that answer your question
now what about you and bob costas
bob is better at certain things oh my
goodness i don't need all of that
do i think i'm better than bob i'm
different than bob it'd be like
me comparing you to steph curry you both
play
point guard but you do it differently
hold on
let me let me give you address i'm gonna
send you a free i'm gonna send you a
free dog with a leech
i mean you scared come on man no i'm not
i i i
own a dog i got a puppy mark i bought a
dog
i did i got a rescue who would you
would you take anybody's answer well
he's better than me at certain things in
certain areas i'm stronger than him
no you wouldn't i i said dan patrick i
know and love
yeah i was not listening to you so what
i got your back
i'm trying humility it's something new
for me
okay that is that's true that's true
okay
because when we when we would go out
you'd be like yeah bob i can't hold my
jock strap no way in the world i'm
better than you
no question i know that is true
i don't mean it i don't mean to tell
your business but you just did
you just did
and you said i should that you should be
coaching the knicks that you're
far better than uh don't do that
don't do that oh now i can't talk out of
school
okay with me saying that they'd be like
oh that's mark throwing a bad you know
good joke at time what you saying
it'll run be a headline
um what do you expect to happen with the
jazz and the clippers because i have no
idea
how to handicap the clippers right now
it is it is tough to
to handicap the clippers and that's the
worst thing you want to have
as a coach or a player on the team who
can i trust who can i go to
who's going to show up how are we going
to play it's unpredictable they can very
well win a championship
and they could very well lose in this
round it's unfortunate
but this is a team i will say this they
don't lay down i mean
they got down the previous series they
bounced back against dallas
they're down against utah bounced back
with a big win
and and another win you know
in the next game really changes things
but the jazz
it's outstanding team that that i say
that a second team
you know obviously the warriors with
steph curry and clay thompson and the
ability to shoot
so many teams are shooting threes
there's so many there's only two teams
in my mindset
that have the ability to have shooters
on the floor and they're great shots
every time the utah jazz
are loaded with you know four five six
shooters on the court
in the jet and the warriors always have
two the two two of the best
if not the best ever do it uh chris paul
and uh
kevin durant certainly chris paul
bringing back the mid-range jumper mark
do you think the mid-range jumper will
make a comeback
i don't think it should have went
anywhere in the first place i understand
the analytics and what it says about the
three-point shot
but give me a basket give me give me
chris paul shooting the mid-range jump
shot
as opposed to you know mark jackson
shooting a three-pointer
um he's going to make those at a high
clip and he's going to punish the
defense
and and they're going to have to make
the proper adjustments
yeah i like it if if they're going to
give it to you then take it you know kd
takes that mid-range jumper
and it it's either somebody taking it to
the hoop or somebody's shooting a three
and uh i like that logic and
even the you know the guys not name
chris paul or kevin durant
if the teams are going to back up off of
you like giannis if the teams are going
to back up off here today to shoot a
three okay establish a rhythm step two
feet in
take a mid-range jump shot is the
easiest shot and it allows you to gain a
rhythm so
it's it's no coincidence why you know
those two guys and those
these these teams that uh embrace you
know shooting mid-range like
feeding sons have a legitimate chance of
winning it all because
partly of chris paul's mid-range game uh
michael malone the nuggets head coach
said that
chris paul arguably the best point guard
of all time
and um i i don't know if
michael has done a lot of research here
on great point guards in the game but
it seems like a recency bias there mark
that you just lost to
uh chris paul and his sons magic was
pretty good right
yes and it's it's i laugh but i don't
laugh at the greatness of chris paul
he's first ballot hall of famer
and he's he's had an incredible career
and he's certainly
uh amongst the the list of the top point
guards ever played this game
but uh he's not he hasn't won he hasn't
won
i don't think that has anything to do
with it uh because we we don't we don't
say that
when we throw john stockman's name in
there he's certainly an all-time great
point guard
and he's on the list also but we don't
hold that against him and we shouldn't
where he went to two
finals he lost against jordan so
see how we see how we taper the argument
he didn't win
he didn't win a championship he he does
the argument that's beyond
chris paul winning a championship will
not make him the greatest point guard
ever played a game in my mind again
we're talking about great great talent
and great great
historically great players magic johnson
is the greatest point guard that's ever
played this game
all right in my mind
yeah it's isaiah thomas okay and not not
i mean the guy think about what he did
he he was and i faced him so that's
that's part of the reason i can say it i
watched everybody and i faced them
and he was absolutely absolutely great
great great yeah but you made him
successful by guarding him
we don't need to go there though the
question wasn't how did he get
oh okay my bad is steph curry a point
guard
yes he is and he's on the list he's in
the discussion he's a first ballot hall
of famer
and he's an absolute you know franchise
superstar talent
he doesn't leave his team an assist he
is he is a point guard
i coached him and i put next to point
guard steph curry
okay okay so you got magic
and isaiah is steph curry the third
greatest point guard of all time
he's in the discussion then you got you
got a list of guys that completely fit
in the discussion where you can place
them three through ten all right where
okay who's third
i don't know who's third i haven't
looked through the list yet but you got
guys
you play the position you know you know
who's gonna have guys like stockton
kid nash uh curry
uh am i forgetting anybody rachel
westbrook
russell westbrook forgive me chris paul
yeah i mean you got to throw those guys
in the discussion and then
it's which which flavor do you like
they're all
to me they're all in the same area and
they're all historically great talents
now who else you putting in there
charlie ward
uh mugsy bugs anybody else that you're
putting in there more
no see i'm sorry but i'm firm i'm fair
but i'm from come on
you you have the disease of greed i gave
you the top two without wavering
now you want to go through the list of
top ten i'm just curious
enjoy how about top five is that asking
a whole lot
no no no no no i said i gave you my
answer when you talk about the first two
i got a clear-cut answer it's soft man i
know who's not in there
dan patrick is not in that point guard
of all time no i'm assuming
no i saw your game i'm amazing because
because you're a knock down free throw
shooter we're well aware of that
we're well aware of it yeah yeah should
i be able to shoot better from the line
than the greek freak
or ben simmons yes because you had a
a full-court hoop in your backyard since
you've been
one years old you lived in the suburbs
you've been you know you had the good
life
all right you're right about that okay
yeah
uh hey it's great to talk to you again
and uh i'll talk to you in a couple of
years okay
no don't do that great talking to you
man stay with me that's uh mark jackson
uh third on the all time or fourth on
the all-time assist list